there's a reason why each and every one
of the six books that I've written over
the years it has hundreds of pages of
endnotes that people can check there's
the reason why
you know after four hundred pages a
culture of corruption the Obama
administration the Obama campaign
couldn't find one single thing wrong or
one thing single thing libelous or
slanders that I had said they probably
audited you though I would bet so glad
to have this next guest she was the
first guest on this program oh my gosh
I'm blocking the camera here her new
book is out sold out how high-tech
billionaires and bipartisan beltway crap
weasels are screwing America's best and
brightest workers and I can bet that's a
censored title that went back and forth
with the publisher you can find her at
Michelle Malkin calm mrs. Malkin thank
you so much for being here
always a pleasure Steve I don't you know
if everyone has to say that but this
show is not always okay so okay full
disclosure my wife did not let me know
that there was a package in the mail it
came this week so I haven't read all of
it I've only read through a chapter here
today but I want you to describe the
book for people out there who may not
know about it and the one thing that
strikes me here is we've been painted I
guess conservatives as the party of big
banks and supporting corporate cronies
you kind of tipped that myth and put it
on its head in this book don't you well
I do it was a was a great opportunity to
go back to my investigative journalism
roots and there really is a line that
you could draw off between invasion
which is my very first book chronicling
all the ways in which wax immigration
enforcement paved the way for the 9/11
terrorist attacks to culture of
corruption which talked about all of the
backroom crony deals and all the back
scratching and obviously the ideological
and you know the campaign finance
reporting that went into that book and
compiling everything that we now see you
know come to fruition with the Obama
administration and in a way foldout is
sort of like a cop
nation of invasion and and culture of
corruption on steroids because it takes
a look at something that's been
neglected and all of the the brouhaha
over immigration policies and that is
the entire plethora of these alphabets
suits of visa programs guest worker
rackets which are the result of
collusion between big government and big
business and my co-author John me on O
is a software programmer turned a lawyer
who himself witnessed what we're seeing
more now of these stories coming out of
American workers who've been forced to
the train to train their cheap foreign
substitutes who are h-1b visa holders
and write that program celebrates its
25th anniversary and it's definitely
time high time that we read Zaman the
consequence is an impact of it on
American workers and American
sovereignty and in fact it is now it's
center of much of the debate of the GOP
presidential field and we really feel
that that we have contributed to forcing
that issue no I think you're I don't
think it would be an issue at all if not
discussed by the GOP so when you talk
about that I guess as far as solution
you know do people go as far as as sort
of like Trump idea protectionism where
we're just gonna punish anyone who's not
here in the States
how far do we go while sort of while
keeping things free and open and still
looking out for the United States best
interest because I'm sure you'll get
criticism from from all sides on that
well I think first of all people really
need to be informed and educated about
the roots of the program itself what was
supposedly guaranteed in the law when it
was created 25 years ago in a 1990
immigration so-called reform law and
part of part of the deal was that before
any American company was able to bring
over this you know cheap foreign
pipeline of workers who are not the best
and brightest around the world I think
that's one of the biggest myth there
were basic American worker protections
and I think that protectionism to come
become a bad word when in fact as as
it's supposed to be enforced in the
it's about protecting American
sovereignty and each and every one of
our immigration and entrance programs is
supposed to be created to benefit
America first I mean the preamble to the
Constitution says to secure the
blessings of liberty not for every tech
journeyman worker around the world who
wants to come here and work for a dollar
21 an hour if to secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
and I say this obviously is somebody who
is a child of legal immigrants my father
came here 45 years ago offering a highly
specialized skill he was one of the few
training neonatologists who is here in
the country went to Johns Hopkins he was
the creme de la creme well when you
actually look at the data of the people
who are coming here on h-1b visas they
are mediocre and so far and the kind of
technical skills that they bring and
obviously that's exposed by the fact
that it is high-skilled American workers
who are forced to train them and provide
them with all the skills they need to do
their job which is then offshored back
to India or China how in any way does
that benefit our country that's a good
point what would you say I guess to
people who are like let's take Carly
fiorina's example I know you're not a
big fan in certain respects and some of
some others maybe so what would you say
to people who say well sometimes if a
company is going to go under it's better
to outsource say 30,000 jobs then just
lose 80,000 overall for the company or
do you think that if the company can't
make it by employing American workers
that well that's just the dice they roll
well I think that the the problem that
John and I have is that you have these
free enterprise preaching American
companies that really act as American in
name only and what they want to do is
exploit the power of government and
these programs to rig the market and you
know that is evident in many of the
appendices that we include in the book
where you've got collusion between
Google and Apple behind the scenes
behind closed doors fixing wages right i
and and the fact is that what one of the
biggest pieces of propaganda that we
bust wide open
is this idea from the h-1b cheerleaders
and the propagandists that there are
some severe tech worker shortage in
America and it is absolutely the biggest
lie that's been concocted over the last
quarter century because the fact is that
one third to one half of all of tech
jobs are now taking by these h-1b visa
holders right and meanwhile you have 11
million out of 15 million American stem
diploma holders who are unable to find
jobs right yeah you know I've always
sort of lived by the philosophy there's
a simplistic version of the American by
American as well and B American by the
best but then there is an irony in that
a lot of these big companies are not
producing the best but they're able to
become and stay big companies because
the government subsidizes people who
aren't the best I'm not really into the
party politics of big business or small
business I'm the party of good business
and that's whether you're big or small
do you think do you think a lot of
people miss that when I think about
conservatives they think about them as
these big Bank people as he and I think
some of them are listen we have some
people in the Republican Party who I
know you've spoken out against adamantly
but big government always favors big
business and smaller middle-of-the-road
businesses tend to benefit from less
intervention do you think that's a point
that isn't driven home enough from the
right because of I'm running for office
right now that would be a focal point
for me in my off base yes it absolutely
isn't emphasized by enough of the
Republican Party and that's because so
many of them are in the hip pocket of
these big business CEOs and the US
Chamber of Commerce and it affects both
and both both those both parts of the
spectrum of the wage scale because on
the one hand you've got the likes of
Marco Rubio and Jeb Bush serving their
h-1b visa expansionist masters and and
it's not a coincidence that these of
course are the same people who espouse
massive illegal alien amnesty is also
supported by the US Chamber of Commerce
and you know as much as I have many many
many many many disagreements with Donald
Trump who had called me me a dummy and
stupid one thing that he
either one thing that he is not stupid
about is resonating with ordinary
American workers and American business
owners who do not want any intervention
at all they just want to be left alone
and you know he was one of the few and
you know we give credit in last chapter
of the book to those Republican
candidates who were have been at least
more than superficially aware of the
impact of these programs and that
includes Rick Santorum and most recently
even Mike Huckabee of course he's been
open borders on amnesty for a long time
but even now he's changing his tune and
Ted Cruz last week who is delicately
pivoting on this issue as well after
calling for quintuple and number of h-1b
visas and buying into a lot of the tech
worker shortage propaganda but there are
a lot of good people on on Capitol Hill
who have finally exposed the program and
I think the one talking point that is
most annoying to us and we're really
trying to educate people honest it's not
it's not that there is abuse in the
program the fact is the entire program
is a beautiful the entire program is
fraudulent I and we took great pains to
amass an amazing amount of data and
analysis journalists are lazy and the
washington press corps in particular of
course is so ideologically bent on the
open borders agenda whether it's you
know on the these legal guest worker
programs are on the illegal alien
amnesty side and we're trying to
circumvent all that and you know really
reach people you know where they can
assess the information for themselves
you know open source is what my entire
journalism career has been all about
people need to just do their own
homework and judge the facts for
themselves well that's what's so funny
is you have a formal you know background
in journalism and you talk about
investigative journalism but you've
always I mean when I first came on the
scene you in Andrew bright but were kind
of the people you know if you could if
you could speak with them and pick their
brain and you were always a huge
champion of the blogger of the person
with nothing but a website you put them
as long
information was accurate on the same
playing field as mainstream journalism
so that's one thing I think you know
when you say that and people they go
well yes exactly so we can't trust me
without a journalism degree there is
such a disdain right now for people
online I mean I'm a comedian I'm an
entertainer I always tell people don't
just use my site as your own reference
for information but we adhere to more
journalistic ethics than most people out
there if something is wrong we correct
it if we make a joke that is maybe
really inaccurate or misleading or like
oh by the way that's a joke what do you
think obviously this book is necessary
but even more necessary is is cutting
through what the journalists have sold
right and this is racist
this is racism A&T mcgrann is what
they'll tell you how do you see the
state of modern journalism going yeah
well I think the dinosaur media
obviously has been upended since the
days of Drudge Breitbart and you know
the rise of the blogosphere and now
we're sort of in a post blogosphere era
with you know so many sources bombarding
us and I think it really is sort of an
educational mission to get people to
hone their radars
and and for me of course transparency
has been you know one of my number one
rules of ethics hyper linking everything
citing everything there's a reason why
each and every one of the six books that
I've written over the years and has
hundreds of pages of endnotes that
people can check there's a reason why
you know after 400 pages of culture of
corruption the Obama administration the
Obama campaign couldn't find one single
thing wrong for one thing single thing
why will Esther slanders that I had said
they probably audited you though I would
bet and and I think that's the thing I'd
say with you know is with all of this
cacophony you know especially in the
sort of clickbait the era of social
media on on the right is that when
people actually have new information to
bring to the fore when they're breaking
something when they're offering the new
perspective and you know when they do
the things that you do just in turn
immediately seeing through false
narratives and being able to respond
quickly in India decimating the this
agenda and these arguments that's when
your most effective and and honestly of
all the things that I've done all the
years it's books like this that that are
the most edifying to be is certainly
more than you know
two-minute hits on TV one second we're
going to go to the web extended version
where you don't have to say crap wait so
you can say whatever the book is sold
out if you're listening on radio lotta
with credit calm we do an extended web
only version michelle malkin knows all
about that stay tuned you see ok
Michelle there's no FCC not not that
you're a profane lady by any means or by
any stretch every well you know it's
funny I saw you drop that f-bomb on
Twitter and I did it for the first time
during the debate when they asked you
know what it was for me my moment it was
ben Carson when they asked about a
supplement that he endorsed and he said
I didn't endorse it I know I use the
product but I didn't endorse so I'm a
relationship with a company and they
said well your pictures on their site
and he said well no and they said well
does that speak to your vetting process
that's when I dropped the f-bomb on
Twitter I couldn't believe how far we've
gone but you definitely I would say this
last do you feel yourself is it because
you're you're generally you know the
term happy warrior do you find it hard
to be that way if you find yourself
being so frustrated as 2015 for me is
probably one of the most pivotal years
in my life as far as culture and how
many countries changed mmhmm yeah
it's this it's this way every election
season
people lose their heads they lose their
sense of perspective and I don't know I
think I've approached this campaign
campaign season with more sobriety and
not jaded this I suppose resignation in
a way because it's never going to change
but you know in one sense though it
certainly has been entertaining and
there has a lot been a lot of upset
Apple carts and even though the up
setters are not you know exactly the the
people that I would have picked
the people that are upset make me happy
right having indigestion well I know
what's funny is when you say that you
know people are gonna go all partisan
politics you're talking just as much
about Republicans and conservatives I'm
only talking about words in your mouth
but you are remarkably consistent yeah
yeah the other thing I would say is that
I mean there are two festering
landscapes right now two ground zeroes
and one obviously is the the political
battleground but the other one of course
is is though you know where we cut our
teeth college campuses right and you
know the last outbreak of the liners at
Mizzou it goes again Steven it just
seems like nothing ever changes
it's Oberlin all over again well I do
think you know I did the Joe Rogan
podcast and he's like that's a great
example
you know conservatives and I've talked I
don't say this to condemn conservatives
and I'm not putting words in your mouth
I'm speaking on my behalf here but you
look at top talk shows right
conservative pretty much all the top
talk shows outside of I think too are
conservative they're not even close not
even close to relevant in the podcast
fear you have someone like Joe Rogan who
gets over 17 million downloads a month
and he's someone who you know the whole
they were sponsored by fleshlight a poor
note a boy for a long time they don't
talk about they believe Moses was an
edible mushrooms conspiracy theorist and
even they they had me on Gavin McGinnis
Milo innopolis in the same week because
the the the cultural pendulum is shifted
where they're going I don't know if I
was always just asleep to this but
everything is racist everything is
sexist and I think the people at Mizzou
the black lives matter for you is silver
lining if you think nothing changes I
think for the first time most people are
going this is this is ridiculous now
this is getting to the point where it's
beyond parody and I think you might see
that swing back you don't think so not
as long as the entire higher edie bubble
is floated by federal student loan
program
you know Glenn Reynolds the law
godfather is the pundit has been
signaling the the burst
the higher-ed bubble for a couple of
years now I mean I guess I could allow
some iota of optimism to deceive into
into Qasim Balkan that yeah we may be
closer than we ever have but we're still
a long way off I'm a sort of elementary
scale of it I of course you see more and
more families families like mine just
revolting from the formal school system
all together in home schooling and so
you know eventually in a generation
that's going to hopefully reap some
benefits when when these kids decide
that they're you know going to forgo IV
expensive overinflated Ivy League
brainwashing education and and just do
something productive and even though for
those listening Michelle bow and said
her children are geniuses half of it I
tribute your upbringing the other half
simply to genetics and that they're
Asian so listen we all know that if you
want to see social justice warriors eyes
go dead like dolls eyes just say what
about Asians in every single facet they
outperform everyone else and include you
know whether it's I know that's an all
income but whether includes Vietnamese
people who came over flee war whether it
cludes Japanese whose parents weren't
interment camps like how does that
happen so quickly and so consistently
across the board and they'll telling you
well the language is more mathematically
inclined if I just just stop it just
just let's stop with it but your
children are obviously very talented you
know it's funny we're talking about that
was talking like this with my dad now
people say didn't I did go to college I
went to college for a few semesters did
really well when I started and then
bombed out just I was doing stand-up and
didn't show up to class I still have
nightmares of that final semester
transcript because I showed up for maybe
20% of the class's dose talked with my
dad and my dad you know went to U of M
and he was like well there still is a
college experience this is my opinion
and I am curious for someone like you
who is is very I would say meticulous in
the way you you raise and educate your
children they're very bright I don't say
that just superficially I argue there's
really nothing in the college experience
beyond the four years of glorified
alcoholism that can't be experienced
with an online degree and a good job or
internship do you think so or am i off
base should there still be a physical
building well if the goal is you know
some sort of socialization and you can
find a college where that that that does
not translate into some sort of perverse
ideological hijacking
then it's worth it I mean there there's
always been the the goal of finding a
mate in college and that's much harder
online although with all these online
dating services not as hard as it used
to be I suppose
and you won't retroactively be accused
of rape so there's that what I say is
that you know my husband and I have
absolutely evolved in our thinking
compared to our parents generation you
know parents and grandparents who who
came here as immigrants or daughters and
sons of immigrants and it used to be
that you know college education was a
ticket to success and there was no other
way around it right and now of course
what you want to do is but circumvent
that by all means possible and we are
certainly open for the idea of both or
one or both of our children not going to
college really no you say that but in
your heart of hearts if you're if you're
oh yes if they have an entrepreneurial
idea and they can convince us with an
investment plan that it's worth
investing in absolutely wouldn't have
any qualms about it Wow no well that's
because my dad said that and I told it
you know I talked you you've never met
my father but I remember I was talking
with Jared about this my dad was really
do what I say not as I do because he you
know he just tested off he was in hockey
U of M New York Rangers were looking at
him he won't talk about this he's like
the most humble guy I had to go find his
records and watch him play in a house
league and score more than the top five
other scores combined in a reach but
also spend more time in the penalty box
I was like he's really good and my uncle
sort of gave me the story on him but he
also you know a pursuit of happiness as
a film with Will Smith it worked at Dean
Witter my dad just tested off the
charts and got a job there didn't even
finish school went jumps from school to
there hated Wall Street hated the bubble
hated the fakery like you're talking
about but still he still had that
inclination where I had to go to college
he would say the same thing with hockey
he'd be like you know I'm pardon my
language bill you know every every wussy
with a capital P and the NHL wears a
visor that the first one to challenge
you a fight and the first one to look to
a ref when you when they when you call
him on it and then he looked a Mingo but
Stephen you should wear visor and it was
the same thing with school I really was
like listen I'm gonna be doing stand-up
I don't but I still had to go for a year
because he thought this is kind of what
you do when looking back he even
admitted he said you know what I just
don't think you were designed for it and
and I think he's learned a little bit
from that so it's it's very very rare
for parents to be consistent with that
and you really if your son or daughter
said nope no school for me you'd be okay
with it
yeah and and both of them know that
already and I think because they've had
such an unorthodox mix of schooling
I mean they've tasted every single kind
of school delivery super shishi private
schools public schools regular ones
charter schools and now homeschooling
with my son and so they're not wedded to
the idea that they need some sort of
credential or you know bumper sticker on
the back of the car bragging about which
college they've gotten into to you know
assess their own self-worth and
successful life and yeah I think that
outside of the sort of Beltway Manhattan
super high achieving Tiger Mountain
tiger dad bubble that this is still a
fairly radical notion but right I don't
know you know in in flyover country its
it's probably more than norm than not
well it's that that's true and you know
I hear this a lot from conservatives who
say it but they don't really mean it I
mean you go through the top hosts or
pundits they say well you know what
about Trace but all their kids they get
them into Ivy League schools and they're
I'm going well how can none of you
actually you know follow through that
I'm not saying you for bigger kids from
going to Ivy League schools but every
single one of them rat-tat-tat-tat
taught you good under Lester most of the
conservative authors right what's the
first thing you read their byline
Harvard Law grad
U of M magna [ __ ] laude it's it we do
have a culture of reinforcing like you
said you had your self-worth attached to
a piece of paper which now can be gotten
online more quickly and more
productively yeah and I think because
we're we were so immersed in the online
world we see I mean my my my son has you
know used science lessons from all sorts
of sources on on YouTube and not just
the Khan Academy I mean there are kids
out there that are producing amazing
tutorials and we're doing a physics unit
right now and it's been absolutely
indispensable to have all of that open
source type of knowledge but just to
bring this back to a policy point you
know you've got this entire federal
education racket and one of their big
talking points of course is college
readiness college readiness and that is
how they sold the entire Common Core
rackets right but somehow that we need
Washington DC to judge what quote
unquote high standards are and spend
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars on crappy pieces of
technology and curriculum that are drawn
by less wing Alinsky pedagogues I and
you know the intent the entire racket
serves a lot of these same Silicon
Valley CEOs there's a reason why you had
I pad and Microsoft and Google all
rushing to brand everything Common Core
and it actually does tie back into the
book I'm so good at this because you
guys are guys but you'd buy
Bill Gates you know pressing for Common
Core on one hand and then on the other
hand calling for busting open but the
h-1b cap so that is absolutely unlimited
so why does he do that why why spend so
much capital you know the financial and
intellectual and PR capital on pumping
Common Core because it perpetuates this
idea that our school system and every
aspect of school delivery are not
producing high skills um
American workers it perpetuates the idea
that there's this American tech worker
shortage which we know is false just by
the sheer numbers but then in essence
what it also does which is very
insidious is because it's actually
lowering standards he's actually going
ahead and accomplishing you know helping
create a high tech worker shortage yes
right yet
Wow indoctrinating an entire generation
hopefully with free college of course if
you hear Bernie Sanders tell it's like I
tweeted this out and no and then thought
of it I'm going to think of all think of
this Mitsu Bernie Sanders wants you to
have this racist patriarchal experience
for free I mean if if people you know
black students any you know feminist
students I'm going okay this is just
this is going to be incredibly
politically incorrect here so you can
feel free to rebuke me so that no one
associate of you but if you are let's
say a black student or a feminist or you
see yourself as a marginalized minority
and you can't feel comfortable on campus
with affirmative action and liberal
professors and free speech circles and
trigger warnings the real world doesn't
get much better and I don't know if you
saw Dartmouth but you know they came in
and they were yelling if we can't have
it tear it down you see that black lives
matter did you see this and they they
said to one girl F your tears whitey
after white tears so I'm sitting I'm
going okay that's not productive right
this is college right now that's
obviously not productive that's not
gonna change anyone's mind but that will
breed incredible racism because you know
what it's not natural this is a mob
mentality it's not natural to feel a
complete lack of empathy to an innocent
person who's crying so the extreme
example of that is we can get to the
point where they can justify violent
actions scale it back they're laughing
at a crying girl solely because she's
white you know what's going to happen
that girl's boyfriend who watches her
cry and get mocked could possibly become
a racist for the rest of his life not
saying it's justified but I think the
experience of 22 year old men or people
who go to college right now who aren't
part of these social justice activist
groups are becoming angry and it really
is so divisive I think you're going to
see more people prejudiced than before
because the complaints don't reflect
their reality
again you can totally just really but
that's the one thing I noticed on
college campuses right now and that's
what's in my opinion so destructive to
the learning experience yeah and I think
that's what I mean by some things
haven't changed because when I was at
Overland in the late 1980s and 1990s
this was really the the first advent of
modern multiculturalism they were
eliminating Western Western civilization
requirements and this would be milieu in
which dinesh d'souza the first broke out
which of course he came from Dartmouth
University himself and his very first
book which I think was his Beck's book
was called a liberal education and he
just examining examined all of the
festering racial tensions which were
stoked by all of these liberal social
engineering policies intended to
eliminate racial tensions right so and
you know with particular regard to Asian
students of course I think there has
been one positive development because
after all this time
many of these woolly-headed Asian
liberal students mostly on the west
coast are finally realizing that racial
preference policies which they blindly
supported for the last three decades of
course hurt Asian students the most and
it's all fixed in that way yet there
they were I mean I went to the Berkeley
campus to speak and there they were all
marching against me as if I was the
traitor and the sellout when in fact if
these liberal agents that were right
back to the stupid selling out their
ethnicity by backing all of these
so-called progressive policies to
manufacture a utopia which will never
exist it's a good point I was asked at
CPAC by an Asian reporter what can why
do you think Asians are so
overwhelmingly democratic and and what
can Republicans do and it was kind of a
gotcha question I said listen I can't
speak on behalf of the entire Asian
community but I think freedom should
appeal to everybody I think economic
prosperity should appeal to everybody
but I was sitting there going okay
doesn't make sense for Asians to be
particularly liberal unless you account
for the fact that nearly all of them go
to very very high level schools and
outperform everybody else so it's sort
of you know we I read about my camera I
read about this but a lot of their
parents came here became shopkeepers
became business owners
saved and scraped to send their kids to
school and they're more conservative but
now the kids haven't experienced that
and they're going to Dartmouth or
Harvard and they become a liberal
because it's the default position do you
see because what's the status something
like seventy something percent of Asian
Americans vote Democrat incorrect there
yeah now that's that's right and you
know just in general broad strokes you
have to look like a type of ethnicity
and I think in general it's true that
Korean Americans tend to be more
Republican even after a couple of
generations and obviously Vietnamese
Americans also tend to lean a little bit
more center-right but I think that
there's a coastal divide and it
certainly has been my experience that
Asian American students on the coast
tend to be the most wildly left-wing and
then yes generations because you know
when you don't experience the kind of
adversity that our parents and
grandparents had to overcome there's
also a general diminishing of gratitude
for the opportunities that the American
Dream was offered and I think that lends
itself to explaining you know why we're
in such dire straits destroyed these
students it is a weird time and one last
point before you go because you touched
on this before we went to the web
extended version you've talked about
journalism and sort of we're in a post
blog Internet that is so true we've
talked about this off air you know
listen the website lied with credible a
lot of people listen to this podcast the
show was syndicated we do a few million
hits a month and I employ a few people
were incredibly grateful but we put out
a handful of pieces of content a day
compared to the average last time it was
about 54 for a lot of these right-wing
sites that have never created an
original piece of content when it
started I remember there was hot air and
there were a few sites where I would
check and go because there was not only
breaking news but there would be
insightful commentary and that's morphed
into the biggest sites just taking the
commentary from other people or original
content and just profiting immensely
have you watched this evolution in
and again conservatives are probably the
worst offenders right now
um where do you see it going where do
you see this finally ending up yeah well
I think you know over the many years
that I've been in both parts of the
business or gold media and new media it
built is frustrating when you're an
original content creator to see your
work appropriated outright stolen
recycled and hat dipped in a less than
generous way particularly among your own
friends or people who are supposed to to
respect intellectual property right but
I don't have any friends I don't really
have many friends in anymore
I just I don't play nice I would just
say not only does to keep your chin up
they just keep cranking out that
original content because content will
always always always always be king you
know no matter how many snapchats and
BuzzFeed's and up were these seams of
you know crowds at the moment at a time
and and and just to you that that's all
you can do is every wake up and relish
the opportunities that you have to make
a living doing what we do and um you
know what you can wake up every morning
and look at yourself in the mirror and
I'm sure I can't say that is true Bobby
I can't I've gained some weight here
with the back injury so I'm looking
quite flabby we can't all be Michele
Malkin's it is a weird time though you
know you talk about that I guess to sort
of go back let's say young Michele but
let's take nothing you know shoot
younger Michele let's say we go back and
michelle malkin getting started up you
know but in 2015 how do you think you
would have approached it differently as
far as just you know again now the the
main conservative websites are just
aggregate us and you know if you write
them it's gonna go viral
no one's gonna syndicate you no one's
gonna support you they're gonna copy
paste it and write h /t in a little bit
a little letters how do you think you
would have overcome it being the the
brilliant lady that that you
it's tough you know I say because you
know that it's a sort of double edged
sword if you're constantly spending all
of your time calling out people for
stealing your stuff then that's
distracting you from putting out more
contact I and you don't want to you
didn't want to have it become such a
diversion that it stops you from you
know that it becomes a wrench in your
entire enterprise I think one or two
choice making you know a few choice
examples of people and helping that it
acts as a deterrent and being public
about it you know when you feel it's
necessary but you know as always in all
aspects of life that it's always about
picking and choosing your battles this
is true how true that is well I don't
ask for me I ask for all the other kids
getting started because I get people
asking me how to start with videos now
and I say you know I don't know how to I
said you know I say this is what you can
do you can do great content you can you
can be original and you know I had
people like and I'm you know you didn't
build that well that's true it wasn't
the government but I had people like you
and yes Andrew Breitbart and Glenn
Reynolds and at Morrissey and people who
supported it just because they supported
the content I told you about this off
air I've certainly won't name names but
I've had big conservative sites
approached me and go hey if you pay us
will run your videos and I'm just like
they were dumbfounded that I said no so
of course not
you you make money you make me sister
you have the ads whether the videos
there of course not well we'll just go
with someone else's video well fine I
mean so when I have kids come up now
when I do speaking and they say well how
do I get started I think you know what I
couldn't tell you exactly it's you know
I've built enough of a platform
beforehand and we're continually
building it but I don't know if I'd have
been able to to get started back then
and that's that's the weird thing only a
few years I mean I imagine if you're
graduating was even like a marketing
degree four years ago it's no longer
relevant things change so quickly yeah
you know I guess my last parting advice
would be for anyone starting in this
business that as long as you maintain
your trust and integrity with your
viewership people will be loyal to you
they will come to you because they know
that your word is
good that your information is good and
you have to build up a track record in
order to do that and so yes that means
that occasionally you know these are
awful things will happen you'll have to
deal with unethical people you have to
thicken your skin but you just have to
keep at it every every every every day
and do you believe in yourself and you
have a team that believes in you I just
I can't I cannot tell someone don't give
up
I can't tell someone well there's
[ __ ] soldiers out there
better you know try a different line of
work because they're going to be in
every free end of the economic sector
and on that not the one advantage we
have it lighter with Crowder is Wiener
jokes
of course Wiener jokes helped us a great
deal I always tell don't trust us at all
especially in this show people don't
know like was this was this real or fake
people don't know because you know half
of it are sketches and half of it is
real like listen just assume none of it
is real and go go read with Michelle
Malkin's book see I tied it back here
pretty well solo out to people listening
Thank You Michelle we appreciate it so
much thank you for watching this video
and taking a break from salacious
internet pornography we know it may be
by accident but we appreciate it anyway
and you can watch one of these other
free videos or click Subscribe by
punching my face with your mouse that's
kind of fun or punching the subscribe
button where we've actually written it
out for you it's all free but there
probably aren't going to be any
breasteses